[Musica]
solo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non male eh quello che abbiamo appena
visto è un estratto dall opera balletto
lesun galante ovvero le indie galanti di
john philip hammond ed in particolare
questa è una scena del quarto atto
intitolato i selvaggi andata in scena
per la prima volta nel 1736 prima che
possa per spaventarvi tranquille non
voglio riempirvi di nomi date e nozioni
ma tutte queste informazioni che vi sto
dando serviranno per il mio obiettivo di
oggi ovvero dimostrarvi che la musica
classica e si figlia del suo tempo ma è
anche senza tempo torniamo alla musica
di ramon pensiamo al titolo le indie
galanti e agli anni in cui è stata
scritta all opera quindi siamo all'alba
dell'illuminismo
beh le indie rappresentavano tutti i
paesi extra europei verso i quali si
nutriva un profondo interesse e insieme
a questo il fascino di una natura
incontaminata il desiderio di
fratellanza il mito del buon selvaggio
quindi l'uomo come animale buono non
corrotto dalla civiltà quindi un'opera a
figlia del suo tempo no però quella che
abbiamo visto una cosa molto diversa
qui viene descritto una situazione
estremamente moderna un ambiente urbano
con tutte le sue discriminazioni e la
danza che vediamo ballare non ha nulla
di classico anzi questo è il club ovvero
una danza urbana di origine afro
americana nata negli anni 90 dagli
scontri feroci con la polizia
ci rendiamo conto che abbiamo descritto
due situazioni completamente diverse
a distanza di 300 anni entrambe figlie
del proprio tempo e che la musica è la
stessa
e questo solo non dimostra che la musica
classica non perde la sua efficacia
distanza di 300 anni ma addirittura di
come sul contenuto si è rafforzato
proponendolo anche in una chiave moderna
e anzi se vogliamo spingerci ancora un
po più in là potremmo dire che questo
allestimento di clement croci thor
andato in scena a parigi nel 2019 forse
più attuale oggi nel 2021 dopo aver
assistito il movimento fly chrysler
adesso facciamo un altro esempio io
vorrei
parlarvi di uno dei miei compositori in
assoluto preferiti e che sicuramente voi
conoscete
magari non tutti lo collegano alle
composizioni che ha scritto e
generalmente su internet non si cerca
così musica classica che assomiglia a
cavalli che galoppano e assicuro che
questo non me lo invento io
guardate poi dovete sapere che ci sono
diverse scuole di pensiero
sempre rimanendo sull'azione troviamo
musica classica quando sei in seguito
che vita movimentata e poi ci sono gli
orecchi più raffinate i musicologi
profondi che vanno dritti al nocciolo
della questione e digitano sarà tanta
era tanta la vantata se fate tutte
queste ricerche
il primo risultato che vi verrà fuori
probabilmente l'avrete già capito
sarà questo
[Musica]
ecco questa è la virtù del guglielmo
tell di gioachino rossini rossini e
amatissimo è ricordato soprattutto per
le sue opere ma a soli 37 anni smette di
scrivere per il teatro
lui dice io non compongo più perché sono
arrivato all'età in cui non si compone
ma ci si decompone ma ovviamente non
sarà così perché darà vita alla raccolta
pesce dove yes peccati di vecchiaia una
raccolta di brani principalmente
pianistici dai titoli più bizzarri
ve ne dico uno per esempio il mio
preludio igienico del mattino tra
l'altro pure in tema copit e questi
brani erano destinati a suo salotto di
parigi salotto ambitissimo da tutta la
società dell'epoca infatti e
riconsiderato qualcuno solamente se
ricevevi un invito al salotto di rossini
siamo nella seconda metà dell'ottocento
l'editore giulio ricordi ospite di una
di queste serate
scrive così così grande era l'ultimo
sabato la folla di una trentina di
invitati furono costretti a stare seduti
sui gradini della scala ma manco la
fashion week quale spettacolo rossini
era circondato veramente dalle to paris
non rammento più nemmeno i nomi delle
duchesse marchese baronesse che lo
corteggiavano ma io perché vi sto
dicendo tutto questo allora dovete
sapere che grande innovazione dell'epoca
che andava molto di moda tra
l'aristocrazia era il treno a vapore un
mezzo che rossini detestava cioè era
terrorizzato e meno male che non aveva
ancora visto l'aereo però uno dei brani
più emblematici di tutta la sua
produzione pianistica descrive proprio
un viaggio in treno e sentito la amp
tiziano presi a un piccolo treno di
piacere un brano figlio del suo tempo
perché parla dell'innovazione dell'epoca
del treno a vapore e brano senza tempo
perché qui viene il bello
rossini inserisce sullo spartito delle
didascalie in francese che devono essere
declamate dal pianista mentre suona per
far meglio comprendere l'ironia del
pezzo il pianista quindi non è solo
esecutore ma diventa anche attore
e rossi ne esplora una forma di
comunicazione di grande modernità che
ancora oggi estremamente efficace magari
non avrà inventato il the talk mal piano
talk sicuramente sì
in questo brano rossini descrive un
viaggio immaginario in treno
apparentemente tranquillo ma realtà
scopriremo che non sarà così
però io adesso non vi svelo più niente
perché capirete voi che cosa succederà
purtroppo per ragioni di tempo non
abbiamo modo di sentire tutto il brano
quindi quella che ascolterete sarà una
versione abbreviata con le didascalie
tradotti in italiano
io vi ringrazio per avermi seguito e vi
lascio con questo brano quindi mettetevi
comodi perché adesso è tempo di musica
la campana annuncia la partenza del
treno
[Musica]
le persone salgono sul treno
terribili dell'evento
primo ferito
secondo ferito
[Musica]
primo morto in paradiso
secondo morto all'inferno marcia funebre
[Musica]
amen il profondo dolore degli eredi
beh
[Musica]